How do you feel when you have a conversation
with somebody that can recite something you
told them a year, two years, three years ago
and you're saying to yourself, "How does this
person even remember the details of what we
talked about two years ago?"
And the most important question is, how do
you feel when someone can actually do that?
Do you sit there and like the person more,
respect them more because they're actually
paying attention to what you're saying?
So Mario asked me this question yesterday.
He said, "Hey Pat, is there a way we can talk
about how to retain information that entrepreneurs
can benefit from?"
We grabbed a paper and pen and came up with
12 different things that I'll talk about here
in this video how you can improve your memory.
I'm not talking about the gifted people who
have photographic memories or eidetic memory.
I'm not talking about that.
I'm not talking about a Nikola Tesla who had
an incredible memory or Teddy Roosevelt that
could read the paper and recite the entire
thing back to you.
That's a certain gift that a human being has.
Certain people have that.
I'm talking basic things that you can do to
improve your memory that can help you out
in many parts of your life, whether it's business,
whether it's relationship, whether it's any
type of thing that you're doing that has to
do with people.
So let's get right into it.
#1: When you do retain information, there's
a couple of things you've got to keep in mind.
The first thing is this.
Think about information that you yourself
remember.
Whatever that information may be.
Then ask the question, why do you remember
that?
So stay here.
It's typically two reasons.
Why do you remember that information?
For instance, some people can remember sports
stats like this [snap].
Some people can remember a quote from a president
like this [snap].
Some people can remember mathematical formulas
But some people can remember some bad times
on what happened with details.
Some people can remember certain laws or speeding
limits.
How do you remember that?
How is that possible?
How do you remember?
How do you recall those types of things?
So our brain typically, the general side,
we remember and retain information that interests
us or information that affects us.
For instance, you will know your tax rate
if it affects you after paying $63,000 in
taxes in a year, hypothetically.
That affects you.
You're not interested in it, but it affects
you, so you know that number.
Or you have an interest in a video game and
you remember certain secrets to a video game
that you need to do this because it interests
you.
So what does that have to do with improving
information?
Well, when you are talking to somebody, and
you want to retain the information, you've
got to make sure that you're either interested
in the human being or the content or whatever
book you're reading or videos you're studying,
classroom you're studying, or you've got to
know at some content that affects you.
If it's not one of those two things, you're
generally not going to remember that content
for too long.
#2: Let me give you the second on here.
The second one is repetition.
Repetition could be the way we remember songs.
I have a certain song that I like and I listen
to it over and over again and all of a sudden
I know the lyrics to it, right, whatever the
lyrics are.
The same way you and I can remember certain
lyrics to a song is the same way you and I
can remember a verse to a book or a formula
or a quote or whatever it is or an event or
details of what a person said, because you
keep repeating it and then it stays [snap].
You keep repeating it and it stays.
So for instance, today I talked to this, this,
this, he said this, he said this, he said
this, she said this . . . - you're repeating
it.
And he said this.
His name is this.
Repeat, repeat, repeat, repeat, repeat, and
then you link, you link, you link, you link.
So repeat, link, repeat, link, and then it
stays.
So that's the second thing.
#3: Here's the third thing I like to do.
Let's just say that you learned something
just now.
You read something, you learned it.
What do you do about it?
Debate it with a group of two or three friends,
or family members.
What do I mean by debate?
For instance, what could be a debate?
Okay, you just learned that unemployment rates
in Panama are 2.3%.
You just learned that today.
You go and sit there with - let's just say
that Mario, Paul and I say, "Hey, why do you
think Panama's unemployment rate is 2.3%?"
Paul gives his opinion.
Mario gives his opinion.
I give my opinion.
I disagree.
No I agree.
No I disagree.
No, it's because of this.
No, it's because of that.
Then we may do a little bit of research, then
all of a sudden that 2.3% stays in the mind,
because you debated it.
And I'm talking debate with people that are
not combative.
They aren't people that just want to win everything.
Debate because you're trying to learn.
So take whatever you learned, debate it, does
this work, boom, boom, boom, boom, it's going
to stay, because there's a lot of energy you
have to use to justify why you believe that
and you have to think about why and it stays,
the information stays.
#4: The fourth point that I'm going to tell
you about.
Share it with other people.
So let's just say you watched a video.
And one of the videos is people ask me what
type of mentors you should have.
I said TEA theory.
So what is TEA theory?
T stands for theory
E stands for experience
A stands for application
So, when you want to have a mentor there's
three different levels of mentors.
There are people that are just theory, like
a teacher who's read a lot of books and they're
going to give you their theories that they've
read and their own theories.
Second type of mentor could be a person who
has experience.
They work closely with Michael Jordan and
they know Michael Jordan's habits, so they
can tell you Mike's like this, Mike's like
that or president's like this or this CEO
was like this.
Great.
And the third one is a person you actually
get mentored by, Michael Jordan, because they're
applying what they know that they're sharing
with you.
And the best type of mentor is the trifecta.
Okay, let's take that subject that you and
I just shared.
It's one of my videos that I've done, how
to choose the right mentor.
Now, take that and share it with a handful
of people today.
Hey, You know what's the best type of mentor?
TEA -- what does that mean?
Let me explain it to you.
TEA stands for theory, experience, and application.
So let me explain to you what I mean by that.
. . That person learned it.
You're teaching, you're sharing, that person
learned it.
Mario, did you know what a tea theory is?
No, I don't.
Let me explain to you what a tea theory is.
Tea theory is with mentors.
Boom, boom, boom.
T is for theory, e is for experiment, a is
for application.
Now watch this.
I've done that three times to you, okay?
If I were to ask you to repeat to me what
TEA stands for, I'm willing to bet you know
exactly what it stands for.
Watch, go ahead and do it.
Go ahead and do it.
I'm going to give you five seconds.
What does TEA stand for?
T. . .. . E . . . . A. . . . That's right.
Theory, experiment, application.
You just did it.
Why?
I'm sharing it with you.
So if you want to retain the content that
you're learning here today, make notes of
it, go share it with somebody else.
It will increase the likelihood of you retaining
the information in this video.
#5: Teach on it.
Don't just share it, teach on it.
For instance, teach on it is this.
And he was explaining how.
. . and there's this and there's that.
It's different from sharing because sharing
could be, "Did you know that Michael Jordan
shot 55% from the field?"
No, I didn't know that.
"Did you know that Michael Jordan one season
averaged 3.8 steals a game?"
I didn't know that.
"Did you know Michael Jordan one season averaged
8.8 rebounds a game?"
I didn't know that.
Did you know Michael Jordan almost one season
averaged triple, double?"
I didn't know that.
Not triple double, what do you call it?
Triple double like Oscar Robinson.
Yeah.
I didn't know that.
Did you know that Ted Williams had two triple
crowns?
I didn't know that.
This is sharing, right?
But teaching is, "Today I learned that when
you swing a golf swing, what you've got to
do, when you're putting your fingers here
and the thumb's got to be over and this thumb
you want to have it in here, and you're shoulder
if it's left it goes right, and if the shoulder's
out and your legs.
. . you're teaching it.
It's different than sharing it.
If that makes any sense.
So share, teach.
So share helps, teach helps even more.
Both of them help you retain information.
#6:Let's get to the next one here.
The next one is, link it to stories.
Whatever you learn, link it to a story.
It doesn't matter what it is.
Link it to a story.
So if you retain information and you read
a book about Teddy Roosevelt's first wife
died or first love of his life died, I would
link it to the fact that my first girlfriend
that I ever said I love you to in the Army,
she got into a car accident and passed away.
I'm linking it.
It's emotion.
It hurts.
I will remember it.
You could say something like, hey, you know,
I remember when I learned a certain formula
of how to do a certain workout, then I'm going
to link it to a story of me remembering watching
pumping iron with Arnold Schwarzenegger on
how he was doing this and he told a story
in that video when he was smoking and he said
this, this, this.
I will link it to a story.
So take what you learn, link it to a story,
then it stays here.
If it's linked to a story that's connected
to you, not a story that's not connected to
you, doesn't interest you, and doesn't affect
you.
Link it to a story and it connects here [in
the brain].
I don't know if that one fully made sense,
but I think it did.
#7: Next one is when you're reading a book,
or let's just say I'm gabbing this book, I
got this gift today from Jeff.
I spoke in the sales office of PHP in Boston
here and so I'm reading this book and "comedian
Mike Donovan used to joke about the Red Sock's
tragic playoff history which included annoying
Aaron Boone in its 11th inning home run in
2003 ALCS."
Okay.
So then I say, Man, what is ALCS?
Let's just say you're not a baseball fan.
Instead, you skip it.
And then you go on an bop, bop, bop, bop.
You still don't know what ALCS is.
Stop!
Find out what ALCS is.
What is ALCS?
Then you realize that ALCS stands for American
League Championship Series.
I believe that's what it stands for.
Now you know.
And then you move on.
Even if you're not a baseball fan.
Stop and do that, because then it sticks.
The fact that you took the effort to stop
and want to study that, it stays in your mind.
If you don't do that, it won't stay in your
mind.
#8: Next, implement what you learn.
So if you learned how to swing a golf swing,
go implement it, and do it over and over and
over again.
And then it becomes a part of you.
You learned how to give constructive criticism
to somebody and it's seven steps.
Okay, great.
Write it down, and go implement it today with
three different people, and see how you do.
You'll learn how to shoot a basketball from
a former MBA player and he told you when you're
shooting, etc. etc. go implement it right
away.
You learn from somebody who's an Olympian
swimmer and he tells you how to swim and it's
going to increase your speed of swimming by
two seconds, whatever.
Implement it right away.
So learn, implement right away.
A lot of times people learn something in a
book and they learn something in a video they
watch or something and they don't implement.
They wonder how come they didn't retain it.
It's because you have to implement it, immediately.
And the sooner you implement it, the more
it sticks.
#9: Next, and this one's going to be kind
of strange but it will make sense to you once
I explain it.
Energy and stamina.
It requires energy and stamina to retain information.
So, if your body is gaining too much weight,
and you're tired, your body doesn't have the
energy and the stamina to retain that information.
To retain information requires your body to
have the energy to retain it.
If it doesn't have it, it's not going to retain
it.
C'mon, Pat, you're telling me my weight has
to do with retaining information?
Yes, it does.
Because retaining information requires an
effort and any time you need to take an effort
to do anything, it's going to deplete what?
Energy.
And if you don't have the energy in your mind,
it just says, "I don't have any interest to
want to retain this information" - because
I'm tired and don't have stamina, and my energy
is low.
That's why energy is a very, very important
game and it's not just about money.
Energy is not just about looks and looking
pretty and looking this and exercising because
I want to look good.
Exercising when we're younger was for a whole
different purpose.
When you're married with kids and later on
you're an adult, you're exercising for a whole
different reason.
Focus, energy, stamina - sharper mind.
So the next point with that would be this:
#10: If you're studying a subject and you
want to retain information focus on that subject.
If you study five, six, seven, eight different
subjects at the same time, your brain is getting
confused.
Focus on a subject and study that subject.
Let me explain to you what I mean by this.
A lot of times people who don't know how to
work out, they'll go out there and they'll
think that if I work out eight hours in a
day, I'm going to build more muscles, right?
You won't.
A good two hour work out is good for you,
but your muscles are really growing when you
rest, because you tear your muscles and then
you rest.
And then it grows.
You tear your muscles and then it grows.
You tear your muscles, and then it grows,
right?
And you can't hit every single body part together
on the same day.
Biceps, chest.
. . one muscle at a time.
You want to retain information, one subject
at a time.
One subject at a time.
Take a subject, obsess yourself over it, and
then you retain the information.
And if your brain is exuding too much energy
because you're using it way too many different
subjects, then it's not retaining, because
it's cluttered.
It's all over the place.
Focus energy into one subject.
#11: Next point.
the next one is focused attention.
Focused attention, meaning Mario and I are
talking right now and for instance, things
I can tell you about Mario.
I can tell you Mario about the fact that he's
a very good soccer player.
I could tell you the fact that Mario, the
way he raises his two daughters and what things
he does and how he speaks to them and what
he expects from them and how certain mannerisms
and when they come to the office and what
type of homework he wants them to do.
Or I can tell you about Mario's relationship
with his family, his brother, you know, stories
about his brother, military, when he went
to visit his brother, why he went to New Mexico,
and how it was, and the drive and when he
went.
When he speaks, I'm focused attention on him.
I want to know what he's saying.
I am interested.
I'm interested and I want to have my focused
attention on him.
A lot of times people don't pay attention,
focus attention on somebody when they're speaking
and they're wondering why you did not retain
the information on what they said.
And all of us are guilty of this.
There's nobody that's perfect with this.
So, the teacher's speaking and you're distracted,
so you're not retaining it.
It's got to be focused attention, focused
attention, focused attention.
And today we have the biggest distraction
and that's this [smartphone].
You keep wanting to check Facebook.
You keep wanting to check your social media.
You lost seven seconds and you just lost the
point that person was making.
Right now, while some of you guys are watching
this video, you got distracted because you
just did something else.
Focused attention, focused attention.
#12: And the last point I'll give you is this,
my favorite one.
So, right now, we went and we spoke in Boston.
It's about an hour away from here.
We're in Cambridge.
We're parked in a Harvard Business School
parking lot.
So we went over there, and as we were making
notes, and I'm going through point after point
after point on what to talk about on this
video, at the end, I added the last three
or four points.
And Mario said, "What else can we do to retain
information?"
I said, "Here's what I want you to do right
now.
I want you to tell me 10 different things
you remember from tonight's meeting that we
had."
He said, "What do you mean 10 different things?"
10 different things.
So Paul was quiet, Mario was quiet, and all
of a sudden Paul said, the guy who was in
the military was an 88 Mike.
The other guy was 23 years old who asked him
about what he wanted in a girl and he said
he wants her to be very intelligent.
He wanted her to be extremely attractive.
He wanted her to be "relaxable," some word
he used, was kind of tough when he used the
word, and then what else did he say about
her?
Intelligence, beauty, personality, attractive,
he used that twice and then he said, relaxable.
Then I said, "What else?"
He said, the other guy's name was Keegan.
I said, what else?
You know, Jeff said that they have to grow
it by four times.
I said, what else?
Well, the one girl she said people in Boston
are skeptical.
They don't trust.
What else?
So we kept going and this 10 all of a sudden
became 20.
You guys came up with like 20 plus different
facts.
I don't even think it was 20.
It may have been 30 different facts that you
came up with.
Names, all these other things that came up.
Why?
That right there [the brain] we worked out
- not knowingly.
That's a workout.
So the next time you have a meeting with somebody,
the moment you walk away, start asking yourself
10 different facts you can remember from the
meeting, and mark my words, you will be blow
away by how much more information you retain
with that simple, subtle exercise.
That simple, subtle exercise for you to do,
and your information goes to a whole different
level.
And it becomes fun to do that.
And let me tell you, your people around you
will appreciate it.
And your family's going to appreciate it.
People that do business with you will appreciate
it.
You'll have an edge over your competition
who is not retaining information because they're
not exercising this area because they're telling
themselves, "People who have great memories
are either very photographic memory or they're
eidetic and they have this, and because of
that they have a great memory.
. . I'm not Nikola Tesla, I can't have a better
memory.
While you are going to go through the 12 points
again and you're going to study it and you're
going to implement it and all of a sudden
next month, two months, three months, six
months, 12 months, you're going to see a difference
in your business.
And people are going to say, "What happened?"
It's called that you applied the things that
you learned in this video.
Okay, so, with that being said, any questions
or thoughts you've got, comment on the bottom.
Again, if you see this video on a completely
different website you can always go back to
PatrickBetDavid.com give me one ring tone
here, boom, you got it.
And obviously, we are super close to 100,000
subs.
Make sure to please subscribe to this channel.
I simply do this because you're learning and
I love all the emails that I get, thousands
of emails that I get every single week, the
fan letters that we get at the home office
that you send, and the gifts and all that
other stuff regularly we get.
My energy to want to create this content is
because I have students like you who actually
want to study these videos.
I'm starting to see a lot of videos being
sent, where people are writing all of these
notes on their walls.
Somebody tagged me on Instagram where he went
and changed his entire office and he put whiteboard
and tape that you can write on.
He did his entire big office like that and
he watches every single video and he writes
all the notes on his wall to be a student.
That may sound a little too obsessive to you,
but you need to make a Valuetainment folder
and start taking notes on what you're learning
in this channel here.
With that being said, again, I applaud those
of you that don't just watch these videos,
but you study the content that we have here.
I have a very, very, very big initiative that
I'll be launching, which I presented here
in Harvard, I'll be launching.
The goal is January 1st, latest first quarter,
stay tuned.
I am not going to give you an earlier date.
We may get it done earlier.
It will be very, very massive.
It's an international project that affects
everybody around the world who has any aspirations
or desires to be an entrepreneur.
So stay tuned for that.
I'm excited about the project I'm putting
together for all the entrepreneurs around
the world which, when we announce it.
The Valuetainment group is becoming a very,
very big group around the world.
I'm starting to see people wearing the I am
an entrepreneur shirt all over the world.
So, the point I'm making to you is I'm excited
by the fact that you have made an effort to
become a very good student by studying all
of this content.
Nothing excites me more than when I get a
message saying, "Patrick, I've been following
your content for the last year.
My income went from $6,000 a month to $93,000
a month."
I love that.
There's nothing more exciting than when I
get a message from a 13-year-old kid saying,
"I watch your videos.
In the last two months I've made $6,000."
I love those stories and those stories are
a byproduct of students who implement the
content that they're learning on this video.
With that being said, thank you so much for
watching the content.
Take care everybody.
Goodbye.